but we have a special guest the
co-founder of the st. Louis chess club
an inventor now an author of a chess
book doctor do you think feel yes and
someone who has influenced hundreds of
thousands of young players to take up
the game in addition to everything that
they're doing here at the club
Jeanie welcome to the show oh thank you
it's always a great time of yours and
it's August in st. Louis nice and warm
beautiful outside oh well but there's
some hot stuff going on inside as well
there's a chess tournament
oh I'm sorry yeah I thought you knew we
were here for the Jester in case you
haven't been aware if this Chesterman
you your thoughts about this tournament
at the time of year I know one of your
husband's favorite times oh this is this
is the best you get the best players a
lot of them have been here multiple
times it's like having remote cousins
show up you know and and since so many
different people have won this
tournament over the years having these
little sort of side bets about will
someone who's never wanted win it this
year will were one of the ones who won
it before but there five have wondered
before so who's gonna win it it's gonna
be a really really interesting then you
had two side bets you know like if you
put the top two players against the rest
of the field who would you pick not an
intriguing possibility but are you out
there or watching this like everybody
has their winner but what you know it's
like who do you really think might win
who's your favorite
I actually each year I sort of like to
have someone who's never won it so we
can say there's something about the
water in st. Louis so so what we
thinking ding Loren this year may be
king and anon you'd like an anon to
ensure he's yeah he's my sweet well like
yeah well like and we'll show thee I'm
older than some of the players so it
would be nice to have someone
show how it's done and we were talking
about your projects and you won you're
really proud of is with the Boy Scouts
of America and the merit badge and all
these young people who have come on to
now be playing the game yeah we the
latest estimated numbers are 250,000 big
numbers
scouts have her in the chest merit badge
and what was fun is in January when we
did actually February when we did the
Karen's Cup the highest-rated tournament
for women and our own commentator
Jennifer taught the chess merit badge to
the first girls who had started a troop
I know the Boy Scouts so and she had
lots of fun teaching them the chest
merit badge
maybe she learned something about the
history from the bed you talked about
how important it was to be helping young
people from the ground up and not just
the elite as you do here I mean you do
it all here but we see the elite here or
the Sinquefield cup that it's important
that we get those big numbers at the
bottom if you look in every other sport
you have Little League you know and Pony
League and you want to find your future
players and you want to grow your
audience so the book I finished writing
learn to read and write chess which is
going to be made available by the US
chess trust for free or you can buy it
already printed it for 2 bucks from the
from the club
but we're because of the interest and
since I'm a great writer right there I
can dumb down anything right it's my
expertise is write something complicated
really simple is I now have people who
have they haven't done it yet but
they've agreed to translate it into
languages like the obvious one French
Spanish Russian Hindu Tala GOG you
bacchus Tong obvious
Farsi Turkish Dutch where it doesn't
mean it's all gonna happen but it's
pretty short and if we can get players
around the alert world to learn to read
and write without coaches maybe or the
coach uses this as homework so that more
kids become literate then when you're
taught will look over there see see how
it says over there on the screen 1 C 4 e
5 you want to teach everybody in the
world to be literate I want to be
literate and then you it'll expand your
audience the players will get better
they can use books they'll be perfect I
know that you and Rex are extremely
competitive as it is and now usually
brag about him getting the high end
you're getting the low end is it's not a
real argument that goes on I want to
know it does it go on in the house not
just on the chess board as well well I
just focus on a different my audiences
it's a different audience you know but
is it off the board to like it not
having to do with chess so you guys
always joking with each other and trying
to outdo each other it's just that he
has other things like I'm doing
invention scouts sort of a pilot program
for the Boy Scouts and and I make in
Missouri a mecca for musical composition
and he's doing the show-me Institute and
educational reform and it's like we
finders so he's doing stuff I got to do
stuff come on it's it's fair right don't
you want to do fun things Frank you guys
are doing more than fun things helping
to change in the city and the world
thank you very much for all that you do
thank you Jeannie hold on I got a
question for you so fast speak a little
bit about the upcoming Karen's Cup and
our dates have dates been made have
people been invited we're talking about
March 4 when the candidates are going
because we because there aren't going to
be a lot of tournaments for people to go
to because their video so we're going to
we thought that would be a good month
it's spring in st. Louis so it will be a
really nice place to come but nothing
finalized yet no but that's the idea I
think March would be a really nice time
to be in st. Louis and people sort of
are getting used to coming here right